when has satire ever been canceled has
there ever been a satire site show
uh uh talent that's ever been cancelled
well there's certainly been comedians
who have been canceled right there's
been comedians who have been attacked um
there's been the comedians who have lost
their twitter pages or their instagram
pages uh for making jokes that were
considered beyond the pale politically
incorrect um usually it's not for
misinformation it's unusual the way that
we're getting you know we get we got
caught up in this whole thing where
uh around the last election there was
all this concern about fake news
influencing voters right so
facebook twitter
they were really concerned about the
spread of misinformation how it would
lead people to believe false things
about the candidates about what was
going on and so they wanted to clamp
down on that and control misinformation
so they started working with third party
fact checkers and they started fact
checking stories
that were factually inaccurate and
writing them false yeah so they could
then flag them and let people know that
they were false or take them down and
completely pull them down they started
doing that with us
so we got fact checked uh the most
notable one happened the first big one
that happened was in 2018 we wrote a
piece about how cnn had purchased an
industrial-sized washing machine to spin
the news in before publication which is
pathetic
you may want to say that one more time
and we're going to put the picture up
here for people to see can you can you
repeat that cnn purchases
industrial-sized washing machine to spin
the news in before publication now it's
absurd right it's like that can't
actually happen there's no real way to
spin the news that's a metaphorical
thing it's not a physical thing so so
the joke is just silly on the surface
but they rated it false and then
facebook threatened to de-platform and
demonetize us because of that joke so
that's a great example right there of
the type of action that's sometimes
taken against uh you know comedy sites
or satirists um
it could be either because of
misinformation or because it's deemed to
be hate speech because you're making fun
of the wrong people did you see what uh
you saw what just happened with dave
chappelle recently yeah of course yeah
dave chappelle is you know you've got
people doing a virtual walkout at
netflix it's been a story in the news
now for weeks
because he he made comments and jokes
that people didn't like so they're
trying to get him taken off netflix
they're trying to get netflix
they're standing with them they are
standing with him which is great which
is impressive because reed hastings is
on the left and he gave three million
dollars to newsome to help save his
recall so right it's not like they
fully agree with everything he's saying
it's just the business model saying
we're okay back in chappelle and leaving
them on there right right it's important
i mean it's it's nice to see liberals
being liberal and actually standing for
free speech bill maher is one of them i
respect who is always coming out against
cancer culture did you hear about what
he said recently
uh it may have been in august like two
months ago where he's having a
conversation about how for the longest
time you know conservatives tried to do
comedy and it never worked because
pelosi is not that fun and he was
talking about dennis miller he says
dennis miller is a very good comedian
but the moment dennis miller became a
conservative and they had him do a
10-minute skit on nancy pelosi you just
can't do it he says but sarah palin
let's face it she's a i don't know if he
called her stupid [ __ ] something he
called her something like that and he
said but
today things have flipped he says today
the stuff they're writing about and the
stuff that the liberals are doing on the
left it's officially comedy there's
officially comedy for conservatives to
have an snl model to make fun of the
left because half the stuff just doesn't
make sense you're making it easy for
them it wasn't the case 10 20 years ago
right would you have guessed a bill
maher saying something like that in 2021
a bill maher who's been known as a guy
on the left yeah
well you know he he what i respect about
him is he takes his own side to task
it's one of the things that we try to do
with our satire is make fun of the you
know we make fun of trump like crazy and
a lot of people that follow us who are
republicans or conservatives who like
our humor because we align with them
politically they can't stand when we
make fun of trump but we do it anyway
because trump deserves to be married
your best articles are those some of
them
we did one on how uh some of the ones
that you read are some of our most
viewed it looks like you looked up ones
that had like the most paid views or
shares uh we did one about how trump
claimed to
have done more for christianity than
jesus himself
and that was it was just a straight
quote from trump trump i have done more
for christianity than jesus himself
now that's believable i find that
believable right because
you're playing at trump's ego i could
totally see him saying that so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you